we have an assumption of war and when we
say the word war and warrior and we
close our eyes and think about what
images come to mind it's usually a man
in a uniform and that means there's a
lot of assumptions behind that if
they're in a uniform they're part of a
military if they're part of a military
they're part of a nation-states force
governmental force they go to war
because of politics they're motivated by
patriotism that's our assumption when we
look at war in the 21st century it's
very different out there right now it's
not just men it's of course women but
it's also children one of my previous
books was on child soldiers there's more
than 300,000 child soldiers out there
the organizations that people fight in
are not just nation-state militaries in
many ways the US military is kind of
like the last of the Jedi look at who we
are fighting against its insurgent
groups terrorist groups and then also
look at who's fighting on our behalf
it's the private military industry this
industry has grown by an immense leaps
and bounds over the last ten years
it's um you've had private military
firms active in over 50 different
countries on every continent but
Antarctica and there's several hundred
of them operating in Iraq right now in
terms of companies in terms of numbers
of personnel by some counts you have as
much as a hundred eighty thousand
private military contractors on the
ground there that means they're more
private military soldiers than public US
military soldiers and just like in the
military they do all sorts of tasks
you've got companies that handle
logistics and supply trains like
Halliburton's
you've got companies that do training
and advisory and technical services and
you got companies at the pointy end of
the spear like Blackwater is one that a
lot of people are probably familiar with
now the challenge of this is that we
didn't set up a structure for how we
were going to figure out when and where
it was appropriate to outsource and then
what were the rules and regulations
under which they would operate and so
we've been getting in many ways the
worst of both worlds we haven't
getting good business deals out of it
because the government hasn't been a
smart client you haven't had enough
competition you haven't had enough
market fluidity and then the flipside is
the legal structures have been very
absent and so you've had this sort of
vacuum in terms of not only which laws
should apply but also a lack of will to
apply them and so the result is that
contractors have been integral to the
operation on the ground in Iraq you
couldn't have done it without them but
they've also been part of some of the
most embarrassing incidents in Iraq
including Abu Ghraib or the nice or
square shootings